foreign
Ville South Carolina Andrea what's up
um so for the last year I have been
wanting to embark on a debt-free journey
and I finally think I have my husband
um ready to do this with me but my
ultimate question is the vehicles we
have two vehicles that we owe money on
and do we start with one vehicle that we
trade in or do we do both at the same
time now when you say trade in are you
looking to get a different vehicle at
the same time through the same
dealership or what well I guess
ultimately trying to to get rid of that
debt um you know when I'm trying to
eliminate we have three three debts
right now of course student loan is
getting ready to start back for me and I
know that we own that together but we
just really made some crappy decisions
with vehicles I feel like and we have
very nice vehicles but it's just a lot
of depth so walk us through what the
loans are on these cars and what the
cars are worth
okay so we have the two car loans my
husband has a truck
um we still owe about uh twenty six
thousand dollars on the truck
um I have a vehicle this main family
vehicle
um SUV and we owe 33 000 on that
um then couple that with the student
loans
um that I have
um that's about forty five thousand so
that's just a huge number to me and I I
just want to do what I can to set us up
for the future well that's a great first
step the fact that you guys are willing
to sell the cars to get out of this
tells me that you've had your I've had
it moment where you drew the Line in the
Sand you said no more debt no more games
we're ready to be free
so do you know what the cars are worth
have you done your homework on that end
I have and we can get more for each yes
I mean my car I could probably get 43 so
that's what 10 000 or so
equity in that and then the truck and
then I I yeah the truck I would think he
the same I mean again they're both new
vehicles get 43 for the truck within the
last year
um no I could probably get about we
could probably get about 30 for the
truck okay so you'd probably make around
four on that one that would leave you
yeah with no cars and fourteen thousand
dollars and now you got to turn around
and go buy two cars for fourteen
thousand dollars
I guess or do we do one at a time yeah
well you can do both at once obviously
you got to make sure you have a car at
any given moment
um but I would not do a trade-in for
these because you're going to get much
better value if you sell them outright
because with a trade-in you're trading
it in for another vehicle
at the same time so those dealerships
aren't going to give you as much you can
see but a lot of these dealerships
you're not going to find good deals
you're probably going to need to go
over to AutoTrader Facebook Marketplace
Craigslist to find a car that is you
know six thousand dollars seven thousand
dollar SUV and truck and they're not
gonna be pretty let me warn you right
now they're not going to be these
beautiful vehicles that you're driving
so get the picture out of your head that
it's going to have the leather heated
seats and uh and have no denser scrapes
in it
okay well I'm going to record that for
my husband
yeah what I I this is what I want to
know I mean you said at the start of the
call that I've almost got him you know
kind of he's almost there and then we're
about ready to hit him with he's got to
sell his truck and boy is he gonna
recoil on that that's gut wrenching for
me am I right yeah
absolutely absolutely has this been
brought up already I can get I can get
this car oh yeah yeah I mean we've we've
discussed it and he says that you know
oh I'll just get a car it'll be better
gas mileage for me going to work anyways
but then the cars he keeps showing me
are twenty and thirty thousand dollar
cars boy what is your household income
um it's 150 a year okay what if George
and I I'm just you know let's let's just
see here what if
I wish he would lead
I really do he needs to man up and leave
yeah but he's not there yet what if
Andrea sells hers all right and she
pockets 10. all right and she goes and
gets a ten thousand dollar minivan or
SUV or something like that
and she puts him in the corner where
she's like you haven't manned up so I
may end up for you and I don't mean to
be ugly about it but you know like come
on he sees her money where her mouth is
yeah and then Andrew now you go now look
I'm just telling you how convinced I am
babe I'm doing this I did it you can do
it too now he has two options there
all right he you guys save up he sells
it you know and maybe he gets a ten
thousand dollar car so he has to hold on
to her or he gets really serious about
paying the the current truck off that's
the other option and so that's what I
wanted to let you know Andrea is looking
at the numbers you know we say the total
of all of your vehicles anything with a
motor and it shouldn't add up to more
than half of your income and right now
those cars are butting up right against
the line and it makes me uncomfortable
and I I like the the LeapFrog going hey
we can clean this up so much faster and
instead of a two-year Journey this could
be a one-year journey and so I love that
for you guys if that's the vision you
have but we say if you can pay it off
within two years it's okay to keep it if
it's within those parameters and making
150 you guys could pay off this debt in
two years but I think one of you should
sell the car and have that level of
sacrifice I wish it was him I don't know
that we can get him there uh just
through a phone call what's the payment
on your SUV on yours Andrea
um it is about it's probably 650 a month
yeah so keep in mind that not only are
you selling it and you're gonna go buy a
ten thousand dollar SUV that's 650 a
month goes towards paying off his truck
that might get him think about that yeah
which that would be your next smallest
debt now of the student loans split up
are they a bunch of smaller ones no no I
actually Consolidated they're all mine
um from uh when I went back and got my
doctorate degree right before coven okay
so it's one forty five thousand dollar
day yeah it is one forty five thousand
dollar debt all right well let's I like
this plan so far is at least selling
your SUV using the 650 towards the truck
and by the way there's going to be other
sacrifices in your budget you guys need
to make and it means hey you're not
going to eat out sorry hubby right now
we're focused we're making food at home
uh we're cutting subscriptions we're
cutting all the luxuries right now
because right now we are not living in
luxury we're living in stress and if
you're taking taking on the burden of
that stress and he doesn't feel it you
need to sit down and have a real honest
conversation
and say I'm not okay I'm not doing well
and we're in this together I need you to
have just as much skin in the game I
speaking of skin in the game Andrea I
want to know is he willing to work a
part-time job or sell a bunch of stuff
is he have you had that part of the
conversation if he gets to keep his
truck then this is what he has to do
have you guys talked about that and can
he do that to add more to the 600 plus
that your SUV payment is now going to be
applied to that truck can he do more
there
we have not discussed that that needs to
be discussed I think more discussion all
around is going to be good for you I
wish he was on the phone right now I'd
be guilting him into all kinds of stuff
he needs to be selling stuff working
because here's where I'm going George
I'd like to see how much we could juice
the 600 plus car payment that we're
gonna put towards the truck that's
coming off of her SUV what if we got to
a thousand bucks 1200 bucks a month
towards the truck and then six eight ten
months from now
now he can sell that truck
pocket enough to be able to you know
what I mean like or just pay the thing
off really fast and keep the truck I
want to try to motivate him by keeping
the truck but he's got to pay it off
fast
how how quickly you think you could pay
off twenty six thousand if you freed up
that payment you guys got intense
oh I mean I think we're making 150 we do
it yes absolutely we could do it very
quickly less than six months
um
yeah I think we could oh I think that's
our carrot we're gonna dangle that in
front of hubs you get to keep the truck
yes you have to keep the truck but uh
you got to pay it off and Andrea I'm
gonna gift you Financial Peace
University and see if he'll go through
this with you watch all nine lessons
together don't do this on your own any
longer and uh we're gonna gift that to
you if you can convince him to actually
sit there and watch it with you yeah